Президент України Петро Порошенко виступив з промовою на Мюнхенській конференції
і, звісно, звинуватив Росію у всьому
Він сказав, що Росія веде
гібридну війну проти цілого світу
і що російський прапор не повинен
майоріти де-небудь на планеті
і це стосується не тільки Олімпіади
Який був його посил?
Знаєте, я залишу Порошенку можливість
доносити його власний посил
Гадаю, в Україні панує
величезне розчарування через те
що ми не змогли досягти угоди про виведення
російських нерегулярних військ з Донбасу
А ми неодноразово намагалися за останні три роки
Знову ж таки, я сподіваюся,
що різні учасники переговорів
Курт Волкер, який наполегливо
працює над цим з нашого боку
призначений Путіним пан Сурков
наші німецькі, французькі колеги
і - що найважливіше - українська влада
зможуть прийти до якоїсь угоди
Ми пропонували, ми підтримували ідею Порошенка про миротворців ООН на Донбасі
які могли б спостерігати за виведенням зовнішніх сил
Нові вибори, відновлення суверенітету України
високий ступінь політичної незалежності
політична автономія для тієї частини України
я, як і раніше, вважаю,
що це - основні елементи
які можуть привести до миру
Однак питання в тому, чи хоче цього зараз Кремль
Дії в Україні і в Сирії
це не обходиться Росії задарма
ні в плані репутації, ні в плані санкцій,
ні в плані російського бюджету
Так, є санкції, прив'язані до виконання Мінських угод.
Але мені здається, що вони не спрацювали
Не в плані того, як росіяни за них розплачуються
а в тому сенсі, щоб змусити Росію дотримуватися Мінських угод
Чому вони не працюють?
Що ж, думаю, коли ці санкції вперше вводилися
і коли вони розширювалися
одночасно з ескалацією
конфлікту в 2014-2015 роках
ці заходи слугували для того
щоб зупинити наступ
нерегулярних військ за підтримки Росії
Мені здається, значно більше
територій могли бути окуповані
якби Росія не відчула на собі
в той момент економічний тиск
Але нині санкції служать
лише для заморожування конфлікту
Думаю, ми повинні використовувати ці санкції
і як стимул до досягнення миру
а саме демонструвати,
що вони можуть бути пом'якшені
в разі нормалізації ситуації на Донбасі,
відновлення кордону
і виведення іноземних російських військ
і заодно бути готовими підвищити ціну,
посилити санкції
якщо все зривається,
якщо справжніх переговорів не ведеться
і ситуація не змінюється
Коли ви дивитеся на внутрішні проблеми України
а я приїжджаю в цю країну двічі-тричі на рік
ви бачите, що чинна влада, включно з Порошенком
не зуміли вирішити найбільш нагальні проблеми
і головне - не змогли побороти корупцію
В індексі сприйняття корупції
Transparency International Україна
перебуває на одному рівні з Росією
Чому вони не провели реформи,
не побороли корупцію?
Це найбільший виклик для України
Це найважливіше, чого мусило домогтися українське керівництво
що вони повинні зробити для свого народу
і це було однією з головних вимог Майдану
Мені здається, що Україна чимало зробила
для диверсифікації економіки
євроінтеграції та стабілізації своєї валюти
Згадайте, країна перебувала на межі колапсу
в той час, коли було сформовано новий уряд
Але я згодна з вами, що в антикорупційній сфері
було зроблено недостатньо
Є низка речей, які...
У мене враження, що в деяких випадках вони навмисно нічого не роблять
Я не хочу зараз когось звинувачувати
Думаю, шлях дуже зрозумілий
і українські реформатори розуміють це
міжнародна громадськість розуміє це
МВФ та інші кредитори вимагають цього
Необхідний антикорупційний суд або кілька судів
де можуть розглядатися такі справи
Це дійсно допомогло б Україні відмежуватися
від країн з високим рівнем корупції
як ви сказали, на зразок Росії
і дозволило б слідчим порушувати справи
Необхідна більш активна приватизація держпідприємств
які слугують дійною коровою для деяких "шишок"
які, як і раніше, намагаються практикувати
старий підхід в економіці
Потрібна нормалізація ціноутворення
на ринку газу і так далі
Загалом, думаю, напрямок наступного етапу
реформ в Україні зрозумілий
Це питання волі і політичної єдності
що завжди було непростим завданням
Але знаєте, у мене є впевненість в тому
що якщо українці будуть разом наполегливо працювати
то зможуть подолати ці проблеми
Ви напевно стежили за ситуацією із Саакашвілі
Як ви вважаєте, чому його
позбавили громадянства і потім вислали?
Це виглядає, як політична боротьба
Він один із затятих критиків Порошенка
Я думаю, тут все трохи складніше
але я не хочу втручатися у внутрішню
українську і грузинську "кухню"
Пані Нуланд, спасибі вам велике
Вам дякую